Daniel Goleman: The central premise
of my book is that today more
than ever in human history our
ability to focus is challenged
by new technologies, by
things that are distracting.
You see couples at dinner,
both looking at their phones
and not at each other.
You see moms taking care of a
kid, holding the kid in one arm
and staring at a phone in the
other, and the fact is that students
and teachers are more
distracted than ever.
It's a new normal and yet the basis
of learning is being
able to pay attention.
It takes sustained attention
to comprehend what the
teacher is telling you.
It takes a continuous,
unbroken attention
to read a passage in a book.
And in a time when we're
raising children in an atmosphere
where the normal thing to do is
to be distracted all the time,
we have to be explicit and make an
effort more than any time in history
to help children learn something
very simple, it's the basis
of learning-- to pay attention.